foreign
what does it mean
to give someone
the microphone
why do we always
show up to church why do we always go to
the concert why do we always
ask someone to take the mantle and speak
the truth you know Jamie wheel he says
everybody worships
but what is it that we worship who is
the one that takes on the mic that
speaks the thing we worship who is the
one that gets to point the way who gets
to be the prophet who gets to be the
ecstatic technician of the Sacred who
gets to be the DJ you know there's a
great line by Alan Harrington in the
immortalist he says we smash our sense
of separateness and temples of
fragmentation in a form of electronic
Buddhism the DJ is the shaman the DJ is
the priest and we do smash our sense of
separateness we evoke with Emily
durkheim called Collective effervescence
where we can annihilate our separateness
metabolize our grief and free ourselves
to the truth beyond the literal grid
where we vanish all at once and we are
born again we enter into a kind of
coupling with something greater than
ourselves and it feels glorious it is
the stuff of myth it is the thing that
cars itself on the tree of your life and
it says this matters everything now is
different I'm talking about a kind of
inverse PTSD I'm talking about a kind of
experience that brings you back to life
I'm talking about the thing that happens
in the concert and I'm talking about the
person that sings the song into the mic
and the person that hit the licks of the
guitar what is this moment where we riff
and rhaps it eyes through a tumbling
Thicket of Impressions and reflections
with such a sharp and vital alacrity
that it can take the breath away like a
jazz Solo or a Jimi Hendrix Solo or
someone preaching Soul Force like Nelson
Mandela or Martin Luther King what is
this truth beyond the literal grid they
speak to and point to the thing in the
song the moment in the film extasis
catharsis communion the flywheel of
ecstatic illumination to come back into
yourself on time and in tune is this how
we get past the thing that fractures us
is this how we find and Forge meaning in
spite of the tragic
and we recover in turn
the magic
man cannot live with bread alone we need
the substance the substrate of song and
myth and story and soul and psyche
ecstatic articulation empowered
vocalization sing the song that
orchestrates the Universe we are
creatures of Trance everybody worships
we all need trance
we all need this coupling this
entrainment this Annihilation what
McKenna calls winking annihilating Glory
so who gets to have the mic
what gets spoken into the mic what is
this what is this incantation the hymn
that finally ruptures that helps us
cross the threshold the thing that leads
you home
what is this thing what are these words
what is this prayer who gets the mic in
song and poetry and arts in Rapture and
Rhapsody in the climactic song of a
Broadway musical like Les Mis do you
hear the people sing singing the songs
of angry man it is the music of the
people who will not be slaves again free
you're mine Neo
I think this is the path forward this is
the only path forward the only question
is who gets the mic more mics more
voices more songs but keep it
rapturous
keep it Noble
beautiful
these are the virtues of the great
capacity for self-expression
we have a responsibility to lean in
Divine articulation towards the good the
true and the Beautiful that is the
responsibility of the one who holds the
mic and that is the responsibility of
all of us who smash our sense of
separateness and these temples of
fragmentation in this form of electronic
Buddhism and divine Absolution where we
bring ourselves back to life over and
over again
this is how we heal this is how we grow
this is how we move forward